as we reach the 380th day of 15 days to
slow the spread
president joe biden is beginning to lose
his grip
on power as are the left-wing
technocrats around the country
so the president is pleading with us
please please
institute new mask mandates i'm
reiterating my call for every governor
mayor and local leader to maintain and
reinstate the mass mandate
please this is not politics
reinstate the mandate if you let it down
and business should require mass as well
the failure to take this virus seriously
precisely what got us in this mess in
the first place
risk more cases more desks deaths
look as i do my part to accelerate the
vaccine distribution of vaccinations
i need the american people to do their
part as well
mask up mask up it's a patriotic duty
it's the only way we ever
get back to normal to cheer together in
stadiums full of fans
to gather together on holidays again
safely
go to graduations weddings
this is not politics it's just me the
president
telling the mayors and the governors to
institute a policy
mandating that you all wear that filthy
rag on your face
because i said so it's not politics
uh no thank you mr president i don't
think i'm gonna do that i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show 50 years in
politics and joe biden
does not know the meaning of the word
politics or maybe he does and he's just
lying to you that maybe that seems a
little more
in keeping with his with his career my
favorite comment yesterday from olivia v
who says breaking news fauci says once
we achieve
zero deaths from any cause whatsoever
then we can all go outside
basically that is what he's saying that
the public health apparatus broadly
it just keeps moving the goal posts
forever and ever and ever
so it was slow the spread flatten the
curve
find a cure get vaccines and then
and then what rinse and repeat and then
well there's new variants
well that you know just to be safe well
the flu is pretty bad too
well just obey obey obey
this is true the only way it's going to
stop is if you
stop going along with it one great way
to have a hedge against some of the
madness of politics is to invest in
physical metals one way to do that acre
gold
you know how the price of gold has been
skyrocketing lately well now there's a
new way to buy gold through a company
called acre
acre lets you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as 30
a month you pay each month once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house just recently
acre introduced a new hundred dollar a
month subscription to a five gram gold
bar
and my favorite product there's an ammo
shortage going on right now
so acre crafted a solid gold 24 karat 9
millimeter bullet
for you to buy right now they're only
making a thousand of these
it should tell you probably not a good
investment if you get it and then shoot
it out of a gun unless you're shooting
at a werewolf that would make a lot of
sense
uh really great stuff it's it's hard to
invest in physical gold all at once
unless you've got
a good amount of money hanging around in
those couch cushions i think it's a
really terrific way to uh
to do it get acre gold dot com slash
michael head on over there start
investing in physical gold today make
sure
you use that url because acre is giving
away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre that
is getakergold.com
michael and thank you acre gold for
supporting the show
joe biden really is a he's a liar and
he's not the brightest bulb in the pack
so you don't you don't know exactly
which it is
what he's saying it's not politics does
he really maybe he really thinks that
maybe he's lying it's really hard to
tell
and yet somehow i still prefer joe biden
to the alternative here are some some
high soaring rhetoric
from the would-be future president
kamala harris
more people are seeing
that yeah affordable child care is a big
deal
more parents are seeing the value of
educators
when they had to pregnant kids
and say we're not paying them nearly
enough
[Laughter]
and then they'll say wow and she just
flies off on a broomstick
this is weird this is weird stuff it's a
strange nervous tic
that she has i guess people have nervous
ticks a friend of mine coughs when he
gets nervous some people laugh when they
get nervous so
i guess this is hers as she cackles like
a witch but
the stranger thing is not that this is
her particular nervous tic it's that
this woman who has reached a very high
position in politics
has so many nervous ticks or rather
falls into her nervous tics so often
this the strange thing about kamala
harris to me is what a bad retail
politician she is
and yet what a good behind-the-scenes
politician she is
people don't like her that's why she was
booted out of the democratic primary
so early on she's she's really not good
at communicating with voters at
p appealing to voters but she is really
good
at working the system as it were
she began her how do i say this without
without uh being rude she began her
political career
in the old-fashioned way i suppose in a
really old-fashioned way
and she worked her way up in the in
politics
and then she made it to a.g then senator
you know i guess a little bit public you
know in california but still she was
kind of working the machine system
then she tried on the national stage for
president i didn't like her there
but i said i said at the time don't
count her out this woman
is a really slick politician and she did
she
she managed to make it all the way to
vice president while being so
unappealing which is why i think
when republicans look at her and say oh
she would be easy to beat let's say in
2024 maybe or
or 2028 i wonder about that
sure she's she's weird on stage and and
she's not really likable
but she's a pretty talented politician
no question about it
joe biden's kind of the opposite he's
really really likable
and yet i mean he's made it very far
obviously in politics he's made it to
the top of his profession
but he he he really is a vessel of the
of the establishment in a way that you
know he's kind of got
the whole package whereas with her she's
it's just this behind the scenes kind of
thing but maybe that could take her
her even further in 2024 and 2024 is on
a lot of people's minds right now
who are the republicans going to put up
one of the candidates that's often
talked about is christie gnome
in south dakota people are a little
upset with me because i've been harsh on
christinom the last couple weeks well
i don't care i'm going to keep being
harsh on christine because i think she
could be a very
interesting candidate i think she did
very very well on kovid
and now i think she's going squishy and
i understand that she's making
certain somewhat plausible arguments for
going squishy but i just don't think
they cut it i think she's missing the
moment she should reverse course
so gnome had the her legislature put up
this bill to protect women
to protect the sexual distinction
between men and women
and specifically to prohibit men from
participating in women's sports
and she wouldn't sign the bill she said
she would sign the bill
for k-12 that she would kick men out of
women's sports
at the elementary middle and high school
level
but she didn't want to do so for the
college level because
this would upset the ncaa and this would
upset
the corporations that are putting
pressure on her and
her argument was well look i don't i
don't have a ton of control over the
colleges this
involves other states and so i'm just
going to go for the thing that i have
control over and then maybe we'll work
the college thing a little bit later
her exact line was unfortunately as i've
studied this legislation and converted
with legal experts over the past several
days i've become concerned that this
bill's vague and overly broad language
could have significant unintended
consequences
i'm also concerned that the approach
house bill 1217 takes is unrealistic
in the context of collegia collegiate
athletics
i get her argument
if she wants to be a leader though she
has to lead
if she wants to be look if she wants to
be the governor of south dakota and
that's the end of it
okay fine whatever she's doing her job
if she wants to be taken
seriously as a presidential candidate
it's not enough
to you know do pretty good stuff and
tinker around the edges but really just
let the ncaa and corporations and other
states call the shots
and look if they if they want
transformational gender ideology
if they want that kind of radical
leftism that will put men in women's
sports
she'll try to fight in her own little
corner but she's basically going to let
them run roughshod over her on the
national stage
well then she's not going to be a viable
national candidate that's just the way
it is
and if she does want to be a viable
national candidate then lead
then lead she knows that she should do
this that's why when she won't sign the
bill
she's issuing these executive orders one
to deal with the k-12 issue good my hat
my hat goes off to you ma'am but then
the second one was this weaker way of
trying to get around the college thing
it's not gonna
work you're not going to defeat
something so radical as the left's
redefinition of sex of human nature
itself
by tinkering around the edges and
dealing with what you know for certain
you can deal with in your state
but we don't want to go too far because
then we might get sued by colleges or we
might lose
college sports games in my state maybe
other schools won't come here and that's
not great and
okay okay i guess then we're just not
talking about the same thing
because if you're just gonna fight
within your own little corner
and not push back against the broader
narrative and the much more powerful
forces that play on the national level
then you're not trying to win the issue
you're just managing the decline
and i don't want manage decline manage
decline is what we've gotten
for 20 years really more than 20 years
in the republican party
i don't want that i'm glad that you're
fighting back
you know in your own little corner but
on the national stage
you got to do a little bit more christy
gnomes says the right stuff
so i i hope that she reverses course
here she just went after uh that rapper
lil nas
x she said our kids are being told that
this you know he's the one with the
satan shoes with a drop of human blood
and
the pentagram and it's obviously a
publicity stunt
that will only cost the rapper his soul
so you know that's a small price to pay
right to sell some sneakers
but she says our kids are being told
that this kind of product is not only
okay it's inclusive
but you know what's more exclusive their
god-given eternal soul we're to fight
for the soul of our nation we need to
fight hard and we need to fight smart
and we have to win great yeah i agree
good talk
good that sounds great when push comes
to shove though
are you really going to stand firm are
you really going to fight hard
are you really going to push back on the
issue where it counts
because it doesn't just count as a
matter of the public schools in south
dakota
it counts certainly at the college level
and the governor has some
some say over that and it counts more so
at the corporate level
it counts in the private sphere
so-called
where corporate america is just blasting
these insane radical messages
to american students and the people more
broadly
so what we're going to say okay we're
going to deal with the stuff in our
state and these certain governments but
hey we're going to we're going to back
away when the corporations and the
colleges and the college organizations
push back too hard no that's not how you
win
not a chance if you're not even going to
stand up to them that's that's just not
not going to work little nas x by the
way responded to
to the governor and said you're a whole
governor and you on here tweeting about
some damn shoes do your job
obviously so many people taking the bait
on little nastax i have a piece up at
the daily wire today actually
discussing the things that i think we
can learn from little nas not the stupid
shoes but from from the music video
i talked about a little bit yesterday in
the show uh as well
christinom's got to change course if she
if she wants to be a viable candidate
because other governors around the
country
are doing so and it's having great
effect on their 2024 prospects
you know if you want to understand
what's going on here if you want to
increase your perception
and your abilities in this
increasingly incoherent world it's good
to pay attention to the news
think about these things also learn the
classics
check out the great courses i love the
great courses
bishop odo wielding a club
comforts his boys by smacking them on
the head
and telling them to run back into the
battle of hastings this
scene is depicted on the very famous
biotapestry and you can
learn all about it with the great
courses plus the great courses plus has
my
favorite class on there which is 1066
a year that truly changed everything but
you can get unlimited streaming access
to thousands of video lectures
on virtually anything that interests you
you can learn chess from an expert
you can explore the cosmos you can even
get tips on how to train
your dog you can even learn about
medieval battles
in england which to me is much more
interesting
i want you to experience that aha
moment of really learning something new
of spending your time
wisely filling your time up with things
that are really going to edify you
so you right now will get a free month
of unlimited access to the great courses
plus
show your support of the show and sign
up through my special url
thegreatcoursesplus.com knowles do not
miss out on this
sign up for your free trial now at
thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles christine seems to be
squandering
her her 2024 prospect here which is
pretty pretty significant
there's another republican governor down
in florida who is
i think increasing his chances
dramatically governor desantis
was addressing the issue of vaccine
mandates
in florida desantis has handled the
rollout of the vaccine better than
i guess just about any governor in the
country but what about this question of
forcing citizens to get the vaccine as
we've heard recently
desantis says no way it's completely
unacceptable
for either the government or the private
sector
to impose upon you the requirement that
you show proof of vaccine
to just simply be able to participate in
normal society
that is completely unacceptable now what
does that mean though
does that mean that ron desantis is
going to say look all i do is control
the government so the government's never
going to do this but if
if you know the private sector wants to
do this why it's the
absolute height of conservatism capital
c
to let corporations force you into
whatever
radical leftism they want that's true
conservatism
and we never can through our politics
reign in that kind of craziness now is
he saying that no
because he realizes that's a bunch of
bunk and so he what he's doing is
doubling down on a message that he sent
earlier this month he's had clarity on
this issue for quite some time
specifically with regard to the idea of
vaccine passports that you're not going
to be able
to go to businesses you're not going to
be able to go to the bar you're not
going to be able to engage in commerce
unless you prove that you got the
vaccine that was developed over the
course of six months
governor desantis says no way
the vaccine passport is a terrible idea
we are
definitely not going to require anything
from the state's perspective that is
totally off the table
if i have businesses that want to do
that in florida
i think that that's more than just a
private decision i think that impacts
our society i think that impacts people
particularly disadvantaged people in a
way
that would barely be negative for our
state so what form that would take
i'd have to discuss it with my folks i
have to discuss it potentially with the
legislature
but i think it's a very very bad idea
look if you want to go
to a movie theater or concert all this
stuff go if you don't
don't but to require somebody to show
some type of proof of vaccination
i think is is completely unacceptable
and it's not something that that we're
going to support here in any way in
florida
love this love this answer because he
recognizes that there are two parts to
the question and he's got the right
answer on both
so he says yeah from the government
perspective it's not even a question
i'm not even considering the vaccine
passport thing
as a matter of using state services or
anything
but when you're asking me about the
private businesses
now we've got some debate you've got the
people who
worship at the altar of the market or
something who say yeah let
let the corporations do whatever they
want there's some people who consider
themselves conservatives who believe
that
and then there are the other
conservatives who say no if
if i'm being coerced into getting the
jab to participate in society
i don't care if it's the government
telling me to do it or some
some middle manager at amazon i don't
care who it is i just don't want to do
it
and he's saying yeah it seems to me that
if a business
is forcing you to expose your medical
history
to get injected with certain things that
goes beyond
just the private sector or the free
market or something
i don't think we're going to do that now
he doesn't spell out exactly
how he would prohibit it because it's
kind of a
newer idea or it's the return of an old
idea on the right that
perhaps we can interfere in certain
market dynamics when those market
dynamics completely upend our
way of life and our constitutional order
and our way of life
and and so he's like well i'm going to
think about this i'm going to talk to my
people i'm going to we'll see but
we're not going to let that happen this
is right we
need to go farther on the right than we
have gone in the past because
for the past let's just call it 20 years
even though it's been a little longer
than that
on the right we have pushed back just
hard enough
to lose to lose to lose on every major
issue except occasionally tax cuts which
then the taxes go right back up when the
democrats win so we just lose
but we lose kind of slowly we lose
sometimes in a gradual way though
increasingly it's accelerating
so that means you got to push back a
little bit harder which brings me to
two guys that i really really admire who
i just think we disagree on this issue
a professor robbie george legendary
conservative professor at princeton i
actually hosted an event
or moderated an event at the roger
scrutin legacy foundation with professor
george
a few weeks ago he was tweeting out
about the issue of critical race theory
and he gave what i think has been the
kind of
conservative consensus opinion of the
last 20 or so years where he said
i know i'm old-fashioned but i can't
help thinking that what makes sense in
academic institutions is not to ban
critical race theory or any other viewer
approach
but also not to give it a monopoly or
privileged position over other views and
approaches
what's wrong with that pause there for a
second because i think there is
something quite wrong with that but
we'll pause that christopher roofa who's
doing superb
work in city journal exposing critical
race theory he responds respectfully
professor
nobody is suggesting a ban on critical
race theory in academic work or the
classroom
we're suggesting a ban on mandatory
workplace trainings
that force people to accept the values
of race essentialism collective guilt
and neo-segregation so
i i will respond here first to chris
ruffo
i am suggesting a ban on critical race
theory i am not
merely suggesting that we ban the
mandates in
workplaces or anything like that i am
suggesting in
in public schools and public colleges
and outright ban on this stuff in the
classroom
and in private colleges and universities
i'm encouraging
the faculty and the students and the
parents and the trustees
and the people who fund the endowment i
am
suggesting that these people force this
trash
out of the classroom not to open up the
classroom to other ideas
and we're all inclusive and no i'm
saying exclude that
trash and
the view that i'm espousing i think is
the old-fashioned view
that's the old-fashioned view that has
rained until very very recently that's
the old-fashioned view
that william f buckley jr articulated in
god and man at yale
subtitled the superstitions of academic
freedom
which is widely credited with beginning
the post-war conservative movement
i know it's very fashionable on the
right right now
to embrace academic freedom and to say
that
in the classroom all views should be
heard at all times that is not a
conservative view
that is a liberal view that the left
has tricked us into accepting and
specifically did so in the 1960s and
1970s
through the extraordinarily dishonest
berkeley free speech movement
uh inaptly named because look where that
free speech movement led us now berkeley
has
more censorship of conservative views
than anywhere else in the country
practically
it is a trap it is a trick that we fell
for this is the exact trick
that i describe in my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is available now for pre-order
who knows for how long but thank you to
all of all of you who have pre-ordered
already it seems that a lot of people
have done that
bill buckley in in god and man at yale
calls academic freedom a hoax
it is a farce we do not first of all
it's not possible
to discuss all views in the classroom
and we wouldn't want to do that even if
we could
in the classroom we do not discuss
for instance how two plus two can equal
five
it some people might think that two plus
two equals five but it
it doesn't that's wrong we exclude that
view from the classroom
in the classroom we do not include the
view
that the the holocaust didn't happen
just to use a popular example
there are actually quite a number of
people who hold that view but we don't
teach that
because the historical evidence is that
the germans committed atrocities against
the jews and other people
in the second world war we do not
include the view
in the classroom that the moon is made
of green cheese
some people might hold that view but we
don't include it the truth
is exclusive and curricula are exclusive
when when you go to a liberal arts
college you're probably not going to
learn
how to be a mechanic you would have
you'd have to go to a different college
that's not what that college is for
colleges have
missions they are teaching towards
something
now colleges seem to have lost their
sense of purpose
though they only really seem that way
the colleges were begun as seminaries
harvard and yale were seminaries they
are seminaries still they're just
seminaries
of subjectivism of leftism
you have to exclude certain views and i
think we need to do that because i think
falling for the trap of the free speech
movement at berkeley
what did it get us it got us the same
exact limitations on speech we always
had
it's only now the speech that was being
excluded was ordinary truthful
conservative speech and and the the only
views that were being included
were were liberal views
critical race theory must be excluded
from the classroom
because it and associated academic
movements deny
reason critical race theory and
associated
pseudo-academic movements reject
objective
truth for narrative they say it's all
just kind of words words words
so the people who develop this thing who
i describe in in my book speechless
describe it as a radically different
academic sort of movement
it's meant to foment a radical ideology
to upend our traditional culture
it is an example of what chesterton
would call the thought that stops
thought which of course is the only
thought that ought to be stopped
i hope i hope i've made my point even
though i greatly admire both of these
men
i think what what professor george and
what christopher ruffo are describing
is an opinion that is very very popular
among conservatives
but i i just i don't think it's the
old-fashioned traditional opinion
and i think we've we've got to be able
to push a little bit further
by the way speaking of pushing further
against the narrative ben
is going to be pushing much further
against the narrative today describing
why
you've heard the name george floyd but
you haven't heard the name muhammad
anwar
he'll be getting to that in his show
later on also the candace owens show
has great guests including jocko willing
brandon tatum john rich
just to name a few and a couple other
great guests i don't know some
really handsome people with mellifluous
voices i don't know i'm just
you'll have to watch the show to find
out who i'm talking about candace is the
first
daily wire show to appear in front of a
live audience but do not worry if you
can't attend the show in person tweet
your questions to the candace show
for a chance to have candace answer your
question at the end of the night candace
owens does not shy away from addressing
the truth about a matter no matter how
controversial
she's famously known for her strong
voice in defense of our country and
holding our culture to a higher standard
the show is available exclusively to
daily wire members so if you're not a
member already go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace to get 25 off
that's candace
for 25 off join now so you can tune in
friday night for a closer look
at her hot takes we'll be right back
with a lot more
other countries are so much more
politically
astute than the leaders of our country
i i didn't think that i would say that
when i was a little kid i never thought
i would say you know guatemala
understands
politics and government better than the
leaders of the united states
but it turns out they do
yesterday the guatemalan president
alejandro jamatei
declared a quote state of prevention at
the border with honduras
as new reports emerged about a potential
migrant caravan
getting ready to enter the country from
honduras the ap reports that in january
guatemalan law enforcement and military
officials
used tear gas batons and shields
to prohibit a mass of 2 thousand hundred
migrants
from continuing at a roadblock that is
what
the police and the military are supposed
to do
when you have massive foreign forces
entering your country illegally i think
there's a word for that isn't there
you have to repel them that is what the
law requires that is what
self-government requires that's what any
basic polity would require
here in the united states we throw up
our hands the strongest country in the
history of the world well what can we do
what can we do and then by the way when
we let them in we don't even know what
to do with the
the foreign nationals then president
trump at least created
disincentives for that awful journey
joe biden's creating massive incentives
for that journey according to the
migrants themselves and according to the
president of mexico
so what do they do they then make a bad
situation worse they cram all these
people into tiny little
cages to use the popular word and then
they prevent the journalists from going
in and exposing it
and and it creates a horrific situation
maybe joe biden should fly down to
guatemala
fly down to a much poorer less developed
country
to just learn the basics of politics but
of course he doesn't want to do that
because joe biden knows this his policy
is not good for the migrants
it's not good for the country but it is
good for his political party
because it's going to help them in their
view get future voters
so they're going to open the floodgates
and give a mass amnesty speaking of the
rule of law
georgia has passed this this new voter
law
that's going to try to tighten up some
of the ridiculous
shenanigans that the democrats voiced it
on that system
leading up to 2020. so the
the big headline here is that in georgia
now you're not allowed to bring
food and water to people waiting in line
to vote
shocking oh this is to suppress the vote
this is this is
a white supremacist i don't know why but
everything's white supremacist now
no it's common sense
there are very strict rules around
polling places at least there used to be
now i guess
we've gotten rid of election day we've
gotten rid of in-person voting as the
primary way to vote so now you know it's
it's
up for grabs usually being grabbed by
democrats
but in the olden days of a couple years
ago we had strict rules around polling
places
because we know that voting is so
susceptible to fraud and it's very
important in our country and so we want
to protect it
there were rules about how campaign
workers
can interact with people as they wait in
line to vote namely they can't
there are rules around where signs for
candidates can go near polling places
they can't be very close because you
want to keep this
area protected from the machinations of
party politics
in the old days of the democrat machines
tammany hall
boss tweed you would have operatives go
up to people waiting to
vote or grabbing people to vote and they
say hey i'll give you a free drink if
you go vote for my guy
hey yeah show up to the bar later you
get a free drink if you vote for my guy
hey here's a little food hey here's a
little drink hey here's a little you're
just buying votes
so george is reiterating a view that has
been widely held re reiterating laws
that have been on the books for a long
time
and saying yeah you can't do that you
can't buy votes that's the rule
let's say that when you go to vote it
takes more than
half an hour generally when i've voted
it takes about
half an hour maybe it's a little bit
longer that it's taken up to an hour
maybe in california
let's say it's even longer let's say
it's two hours
let's say i'm gonna give the crazy left
the benefit of the doubt
let's say it's three hours wait in line
to vote
let first of all if you really get
famished during that time or you really
get thirsty
bring a bottle of water shove a granola
bar in your pocket
but let's say let's say you forgot
if you cannot go three hours without
stuffing your face something is wrong
with you
something has you need to put the
cupcake down if you cannot go three
hours
without having a little nibble our
bodies were made
to go more than three hours without a
muffin
you will survive i promise you you will
survive
but of course these are not these are
not the real concerns of democrats in
georgia
or the national democrats looking at
georgia they want to be able to buy
votes and to get really close to the
polling place when they can't pry people
away from the polling place in the first
place and get them to vote by mail
and maybe get a few of their dead
cousins to vote by mail too
it's all about it's about race this is
you know it's white supremacy
to prevent democrat operatives from
bribing voters with drinks and
candies and things cnn's dana bash
was shocked horrified it's too bad i
actually kind of like dana bash she's
done some
some pretty good interviews recently but
she just goes back to that typical
democratic narrative very often
she was shocked and appalled that
georgia governor brian kemp would sign
this new vote integrity bill
in a room of that of the worst
beast that has ever roamed the earth
white
men joining me now is democratic georgia
senator
reverend rafael warnock senator reverend
thank you so much for joining me this
morning i want to put
up that picture of governor brian kemp
signing this law in a room full of white
men
a room full of white men he's saying
that we can't send our operatives to go
give people slices of pizza at the polls
in a room full of white men everyone
knows white men don't need to eat
everyone it's just basic science white
men don't need water to survive
it's so odd these white men they know
they know that if they they deprive
voters of color
of snacks at the polling place know that
they will suppress the vote
imagine i mean it's become cliche i
don't i almost don't want to say it but
imagine if somebody went
forget on cnn let's say somebody on on a
conservative news channel went out and
said
you know i can't believe that uh that
this
well we'll refer to the true governor of
georgia stacy abrams i still think she
hasn't conceded that race from a couple
years ago
if if a conservative went on tv and said
can you believe
that stacey abrams signed this bill into
law in a room full of black women
ugh makes me sick terrible
did you imagine the reaction but of
course there's they're not playing fair
so it's
it's almost pointless even to mention it
everything even the least racially
relevant questions need to come down to
race
when it is in any way convenient
people don't need to have any idea what
they're talking about they just know
that that's a trump card and usually
it's going to work occasionally it
doesn't work
as we saw last night on bill maher heidi
heitkamp
the former senator from north dakota
not not the brightest bulb in the pack i
think there was one time a
friend of mine was going down to to
serve in congress
and uh we were talking to a
long-standing
u.s congressman and we asked hey what
what should you what should we know
about congress you know what should we
know about the halls of congress
and this long-standing congressman whose
name i won't mention said well
you're going to be disappointed the iq
on average is not so high there and
heidi heitkamp
in her comments last night i think
proved this point
though fortunately she's no longer in
the senate she went on bill maher's show
and they they were addressing my my
colleague here gina carano
the movie star and mma fighter and heidi
heitkamp just just casually just said
gina carano she's a she a nazi everybody
knows that
i like this picture uh who was the woman
in the
mandalorian what did she do she liked
something she was a nazi
oh that's different right i'm thinking
of somebody well she's not a nazi she's
she was
she's awake
um she does hang with white supremacists
it's like a mel brooks does
yeah hangs with whites i suppose i'm now
get subject to defamation
i i don't know i mean it depends on what
your definition of white supremist is
that you're so
the goal post there changed a lot you
should be a guy in a clan hood who
but i think we have to i think we have
to be really careful there's two things
the republicans think they're gonna get
biden on
cancel culture and this whole dr seuss
stuff that's going on where they're
reading
green eggs and ham proving that some of
these senators can actually read
and and um and
and immigration and and and so
we can't ignore the fact that we got
donald trump was in part because of
political correctness
oh i hope gina does sue her for
defamation i i don't think she will
because defamation suits are just really
really hard to win and you spend a lot
of money on lawyers in it if you're a
public figure it usually doesn't work
but i hope she does because
what heidi heitkamp here is saying is
just completely indefensible
and and worse than the slander of it all
is the
laziness to say this woman doesn't know
a thing about gina carano this woman has
probably never googled gina carano
but she reads some facebook post
from i don't know her like blue-haired
niece or something that said gina
carano's a nazi and that's all that's
all it takes
so yeah no she's a nazi and then bill
maher to his credit he goes a little
light on her but at least he calls her
out he says what
wait i think he thought she was kidding
at first he goes oh yeah yeah everyone's
a nazi wait are you really saying
that heidi wait oh you she's a nazi and
then heidi realizes
she's like uh oh i thought i could just
get away with this casual this drive-by
slander
now i'm being called out on it now i
actually have to defend my views but i
can't because i have no idea what i'm
talking about
oh and then she tries to dial it back so
she dials it back from nazi from
literally hitler to
well you know she but she's no she's a
white supremacist i'm not
yeah no oh yeah everyone knows that
right please let me get away with this
bill please
wait what you're she's how's she a white
supremacist and then bill tries to
dig her out of it a little bit he's like
well i guess it depends what
your definition of white supremacist is
but what how do you
and then then heidi tries to bring it
back even further he goes oh yeah no she
hangs
with white white supremacists and she uh
she
uh uh uh who who what do you know about
anything heidi height nothing
and then the other guy who the
libertarian guy his name i forget at the
moment but he
uh he comes out he defends gina i think
quite well and says
no she just she compared the actions
of some other people to some actions
that the nazis did she
she made a comparison she's not she
didn't even call anybody nazis and she
certainly if you accuse someone of being
a nazi as though that were a terrible
thing
you yourself probably wouldn't embrace
the label nazi right it's just so
stupid it's just so incredibly lazy
and then and then i love my the button
on the whole interview and she goes
yeah and no but bill you know hold on i
can't defend my views so
uh i think we need to be really careful
you need to be really careful you just
called a woman a nazi without any
evidence whatsoever
without knowing a thing about her and we
need to be careful and then she pivots
and tries to talk about something else
it's vermont she got caught in the way
it was
i keep going back to this because it was
so funny a black democrat lady called in
to david webb's radio show
once and he made a a good point and she
said well you only think that because of
your white privilege
and i guess she didn't know she never
met david webb and so what
david webb goes ma'am i don't think you
would say that if you knew me she goes
no you are it's because you're white
privileged david webb of course is
very much a black man and uh so he goes
uh ma'am i'm
a black guy and she she says oh
okay well anyway you know it doesn't
matter
it's not the the claim the charge of
white supremacy or
nazism or whatever that's not the
conclusion of an argument
that's the premise that's where that's
where they're starting from
and then if the premise is proven wrong
oh too bad or i will try something else
but usually they don't get called out on
the premises so they just get to
continue
the smears by the way this is this is
not just affecting these radical
democratic senators or media people
kind of stuff is going on in the
military u.s special operations command
has an office of diversity inclusion
they appoint a guy to that richard
therese estrada
and it turns out that this guy the
diversity and inclusion officer at the
u.s special operations command
once at least once compared trump
to hitler did the same thing that heidi
heitkamp did
except this guy is not at least
apparently he's not a
democrat operative obviously in practice
he's a democrat operative
but he's a he's a member he's a
leading figure within a certain segment
of the military
he's even infected that military is
investigating this incident there's no
need to investigate this incident what's
the reason to investigate it
i think anybody i think i'm willing to
make this claim
every single person who who serves as a
diversity and inclusion officer
in any position in this country has at
some point compared trump to hitler
i i would bet a lot of money that that
statement is true
okay the real issue here is not that
this one
diversity and inclusion officer made
this ridiculous comparison and smeared
the president
the issue is that we have diversity and
inclusion officers in our military
i don't i don't want diversity in the
military and i mean i don't care what
race they are or anything like that
here's here's the i want unity in the
military and here's the unity i want
love of country the willingness to kill
our enemies and the ability to kill our
enemies that's what i want those three
things i want that unity
i don't want diversity in that some
people who want to kill our enemies and
some people want to hug our enemies
that's bad diversity i don't want that
it's a bad idea mission drift has set in
here
but we let this happen as conservatives
we just well okay maybe we can have a
diversity inclusion officer but you know
they can't compare trump to nazis no
just get rid of it it's ridiculous why
on earth
is is what has been and what ought to be
the most lethal
formidable fighting force on earth
wasting
our precious resources and their
precious time
on this ridiculous nonsense of diversity
and inclusion officers get rid of it the
guy should be fired whether he did it or
not because the position
should not exist this sort of
radical racialism
the the uh exaltation of diversity and
inclusion whatever other
pc terms you want is not unique to the
united states it's going on all around
the western world
dannon down in australia way down under
there there is a school in victoria
australia
that is having their young teenage boys
uh at a at an assembly stand up
and apologize to girls on behalf
of their gender on behalf of their
gender
some parents were pretty outraged by
this that 12 year old boys were made to
apologize
for just being boys
uh and so i think the school finally did
apologize this is going on
in a lot of different places
all these i'm sure the boys were
apologizing they're like i'm sorry that
my
male sex picks up the check for dinner
i'm
sorry that my male sex historically has
fought all the wars ever
i'm sorry that my male sex
dies a little earlier on average because
we we work a lot i'm so i don't know
what are we going to apologize for i'm
sorry
that we've yeah we could go on and on
and on the
diversity and inclusion thing and and
whatever other
politically correct initiatives that are
being foisted on us
are not about equality they're not about
fairness
they're not about restoring some neutral
ground where we can all
sing kumbaya they're about punishment
they're about
castigating men the patriarchy they're
about to cast castigating
white people they're about castigating
uh i guess straight people now i guess
is that that's part of it i guess uh
i guess people who know that they are
the sex that they are
that's and now with the advent of trans
ideology
it's about to use a popular left-wing
term
otherwising a very small group of people
and saying that they're the source of
all the evil in the world
and that even when racial minorities
attack other racial minorities the cause
of that is white supremacy which
which left-wingers actually have said in
the last couple weeks
and reordering
society away from any semblance of
justice equality
or fairness it is not enough to just
sort of mildly push back against that
it is not enough to say we will hear all
views and tolerate no
you need to assert an alternative
political vision and alternative moral
vision
the left is asserting political and
moral vision it's immoral and it'll
destroy our politics
but got to give them credit at least
they have the courage to to make that
vision what are we doing on the right we
just get lost in these abstract
ridiculous procedural arguments
about defending free speech in the
abstract totally divorced from the
actual american tradition of free speech
very often we make arguments that are
contrary to the actual tradition of free
speech
here in america we talk about we need
academic freedom we never talk about the
actual
academic tradition in the united states
and in the west
now we don't talk about the substance we
only talk about the procedure
not good stuff you know i i explain this
problem and
outline a way out in i don't know if
i've mentioned it before my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds which is available
now for pre-order this probably will not
be
put on many high school curricula
certainly not in public schools maybe
not in many private schools
but i do hope that people read this book
whether it's in public or private school
i promise you
the democrat governor of kentucky andy
beshear did not read it
because andy beshear is is showing us
the the double standards that the left
is always using
the left right now is very focused on
maintaining the support of teacher
unions and so they're very opposed to
reopening schools
and they're also very opposed to school
choice so for a lot of kids
the only way that they're going to
escape or by far the greatest chance
they have to escape
poverty bad conditions and even just bad
culture and even just bad interpersonal
relationships is through education
that's the way out never met a guy at
the top who doesn't read a lot
who hasn't educated himself there are
very very few
very few people who've made i guess
there are a few exceptions especially in
like you know
hollywood or some of the crazy liberals
out there but generally speaking the
people who make it to the top of the
heap
are pretty pretty well educated so this
governor this democrat governor is
sends his kids to private school but he
himself
will not allow other students to have
that same school choice
when he's pushed back on about this
he says well yeah i send my kids to
private school but i am a public
school graduate but in your most
precious
investors investment your own children
they go to pub to private school
why don't they go to public school and
is that kind of a is that hypocritical
that your children go to private school
i'm a public school graduate i believe
in public schools and my kids will be
going to a public middle school
so he's been saying a lot a lot a lot
i'm a product of the public schools well
it turns out there's a report just came
out
that andy beshear at least for some
period
of his schooling went to private school
and he's never disclosed this
when he talks about how much he loves
public schools
this is not surprising this has happened
to other politicians too
they they get caught up in this lie they
want certain privileges
for themselves they want to exclude
those privileges
from other people and this is especially
true during the coronavirus how many
times has dr fauci been caught
in close proximity to other people
without his mask on after he told
everyone to wear masks
countless times at this point he's been
photographed doing it filmed doing it
then he sees people have cameras on him
and he pulls the mask back up
certain rules for the for the peasants
and certain rules for the
elites now they want to extend this
forever and ever and ever
you might have thought i was being
hyperbolic when i said this sort of
thing a year ago
i said oh michael it'll be okay it won't
be two weeks but it'll be two months
three months we'll get back to normal
380 days my friends and now they're
calling not to start letting up
they're calling for renewed mask
mandates the president
of the united states wants renewed mass
mandates everywhere in the country
and then they want you to put your
medical history on an
app to prove to people that you've
gotten their shot
that was developed quickly seems to be
doing well but still you know it's
developed pretty quickly
they want to force you to get that shot
to engage in commerce and it's not just
that one shot it'll track variants it'll
track boosters
the power will not go away they will not
give up that power
unless we stop allowing them to have it
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 today on the ben shapiro show a
pakistani american man
is murdered by two female black
teenagers but that's not national news
meanwhile the derek chavin trial begins
the left's agenda is obvious that's
today on the ben shapiro show give it a
listen